bonsoir à tous ravis de vous retrouver à
la une de ça vous regarde ce soir d
entreprise couverte de honte même un
schème le gouvernement vient de publier
les résultats d'une vaste opération de
testing cette grande entreprise sont
épinglés pour des soupçons de
discrimination à l'embauché alors
s'appeler mohamed dans notre pays est
toujours plus difficile que de simples
etc tron soit pour trouver un emploi
comment on en finit avec ça on en parle
dans un instant dans notre grand débat
est les réalisatrices productrices
engagé ses héroïnes raconte la vie de
destins de femmes à cheval entre deux
cultures souvent des destins d'immigrés
elle a été élue aussi puis ministre
avant de se détourner de la politique
yamina benguigui et notre grand témoin
ce soir sans oublier bien sûr notre club
du vendredi on va refaire la semaine
politique avec nos joyeux chroniqueurs
voilà vous savez tout hashtag sévère
n'oubliez pas c'est parti on y va
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'avoir choisi lcp
nos invités en plateau ce soir yamina
benguigui
bonsoir et merci d'être notre grand
témoin on a une heure à passer ensemble
dans cette émission réalisatrice le
tournage de votre dernier film avec
isabelle adjani vient de se terminer
j'espère que vous nous en dire un mot
tout à l'heure vous avez été ministre
déléguée à la francophonie sous françois
hollande passionné par l'afrique aussi
votre dernier documentaire était
consacrée au bassin forestier du congo
ça s'appelle le dernier poumon du monde
on n'en dira un mot puisque vous vous
apprêtez à partir en tournée dans
plusieurs pays dans lesquels ce
documentaire va être diffusée mais
l'actualité ce soir c'est un sujet que
vous connaissez très bien les
discriminations à l'embauché
c'est le plus grand testing jamais
réalisée en france sur l'emploi en tous
les cas c'est comme ça que le
gouvernement a présenté cette étude
hier et c'est vous qui l'avez
coordonnées yannick l'horty bonsoir
merci d'être là vous êtes économiste à
l'université paris est créteil et vous
nous direz comment vous avez travaillé
hermann ebongue bonsoir soit merci
d'être là secrétaire général de sos
racisme le testing vous connaissez
puisque l soes le pratique depuis des
années vous nous direz si ces résultats
vous surprennent benoît c'est remercie
d'être là pour présenter les directeurs
de ressources humaines vice président de
l'association nationale des drh enfin
mahdia et bonsoir et bienvenue
vous êtes député la république en marche
des yvelines trapel en cours la verrière
entre autres villes dans votre
circonscription je vous donne la parole
dans un instant celui qui va nous
planter le décor au fond de ce grand
estime que de ces résultats c'est
stéphane stéphane blakowski dans son
billet si j'ai bien compris tout de
suite
bonsoir mesdames % myriam bon score et
femmes installés vous si j'ai bien
compris ce soir alors si j'ai bien
compris ça fait des années et des années
qu'on dénonce la discrimination à
l'embauché
et pourtant aujourd'hui en france c'est
toujours un handicap d'avoir un nom à
consonance arabe
quand on cherche du boulot donc je vais
vous montrer un graphique qui est tiré
de l'étude commandée le gouvernement
près de chercheurs qui bossent pour le
cnrs si je me trompe pas donc ça rapport
de 35 pages on à la télé je montre un
petit graphique qui résume j'ai choisi
le taux de réponses positives selon
l'origine et lieu de résidence dans sa
série les candidatures spontanées envoyé
à 103 très grandes entreprises
françaises ont déjà on a peu de chance
de recevoir une réponse voyez on truque
10% même pour les mieux lotis
qui sont les gens qui ont un nom
français qui habite dans un quartier
neutre c'est-à-dire pas spécialement
réputé difficile mais hop déjà sur la
vie dans un quartier difficile avec un
nom français les chances d'avoir une
réponse positive baisse et bien sûr que
ceux qui ont le moins de chance et ceux
qui ont un nom à consonance arabe
même s'il habite dans un quartier
neutres ils sont ils partent déjà
pénalisés avec 20% de chances en moins
donc j'imagine que si en plus il
habitait dans un quartier difficile
catégorie n'est pas représentée ce sera
encore plus cumuler et difficultés alors
c'est un constat accablant
pourquoi est ce que ces discriminations
à l'embauché persiste alors qu'il faut
le rappeler c'est inégal
alors moi j'ai bossé quelques heures
d'eps eu seulement mais ce qui m'a paru
frappant c'est quand même un gros
contraste entre eux les discours d'un
côté les actes de l'autre parce que ça
des beaux discours pour lutter contre la
discrimination à l'embauché rien a eu le
plein mais c'est les actes qui ont eu ou
aurait eu du mal à suivre l'exemple
bah oui parce ça tombe bien vous me
posez la question parce que j'ai un
exemple évidemment fait le cv anonyme
donc vous souvenez qu'en 2006 dominique
villepin dit bon l'égalité des chances
il faut un cv anonyme donc l'assemblée
vote une loi pour le cv anonyme qui
paraît l'armé absolue contre la
discrimination de ce qu'il n'y a que les
compétences du candidat
y'a pas son nom il ya passe à fossa
photo ja pas son adresse
même pas son âge donc le seul problème
c'est que la loi est votée
ok on applaudit mais le décret
d'application n'est jamais publié donc
ce qui fait que la loi ne s'applique pas
donc voilà les bras vous en tombent en
2011 il ya des gens qui disent c'est pas
normal ont saisi le conseil d'état en
2014 au conseil d'état dit au
gouvernement vous
et puis le décret qui est publié en 2015
simplement on a modifié la loi avant et
c'est plus obligatoire le cv anonyme
c'est juste facultative ailleurs tout le
monde est contraint discrimination à
l'embauché ya aucun problème mais
pourtant alors l'impression que les
actes suivent pas mon fort alors
justement qu'est-ce qui l'a fait le
président de la république en la matière
a exigé pas besoin d'une révolution je
dirais que dans la tradition au fait de
la lutte contre la discrimination qui
doit toujours commencer par bon discours
plein de bonnes résolutions
c'est sur moi parce qu'elle sait faire
on l'écouté en novembre 2010 est à
tourcoing je veux que dans le travail de
l'inspection du travail il justement des
enquêtes spécifiques pour aller chercher
les employeurs qui et c'est parfaitement
traçable parfaitement vérifiables cela a
été conduit à travers plusieurs
opérations dites de testing puisse
traquer ceux qui ne respectent pas ce
qui est dans la loi ce qui est dans
notre code du travail qui interdit la
discrimination à l'embauché comme à la
promotion
voilà on est en 2010 est donc m nl mâcon
vient d'être élu en novembre précisément
depuis est-ce que ce discours a été
suivi d'effet ah bin là vous avez un
petit peu vite
là c'est non mais c'était juste premier
discours après il ya eu un deuxième
discours en 2018 pour dire la même chose
histoire que vraiment de bien préciser
que ce n'est pas bien à discriminer sur
la bouche en demie 19 hier bien eu
peut-être que le gilet jaune qui vont un
peu dispersé l'actuel gouvernement là
rassurez vous on est en 2020 et enfin
des mesures puisqu'on a publié le nom de
cette très grande entreprise ou les
chercheurs ont vu qu'il y avait
manifestement c'était un handicap
d'avoir un nom à consonance arabe pour
être embauché donc évidemment les
entreprises disent maintenant il ya un
problème entre la méthodologie sais
c'est pas c'est pas les bons résultats
puis surtout elle proteste élise nous la
discrimination mais jamais au grand
jamais alors moi je ne sais pas la
méthodologie
simplement il ya juste un paradoxe c'est
que tout le monde est contre la
discrimination à l'embauché
et pourtant aujourd'hui en france c'est
un handicap d'avoir un an concernant sa
rapporteure du boulot eh ben on va en
débattre merci stéphane avant de se
demander justement si les réponses du
gouvernement sont à la hauteur du
problème on va revenir avec vous et
yannick l'horty sur cette opération de
testing que vous avez coordonné comment
avez vous travaillé un peu moins 18000
candidature tester comment vous avez
procédé précisément alors d'abord on
répond à une demande du gouvernement qui
qui consiste à tester
40 entreprises parmi les 120 plus
grandes capitalisations boursières en
france et qui demande à faire un test
multicritères dans lequel on va regarder
à la fois l'effet de l'origine et
l'effet de l'adresse et donc par rapport
à cette demande nous conte et puis par
ailleurs on avait un calendrier assez
contraint et par rapport à cette demande
ce qu'on a proposé c'est donc plusieurs
innovations ont dit le les méthodes ne
change pas en matière de testing en fait
il ya plusieurs innovations dans cette
dans cette campagne
la principale c'est qu'on a fait un test
multicanal
non seulement on a testé des offres
d'emploi comme on le fait habituellement
mais en matière de tests d'offres
d'emploi on se heurte à des difficultés
de plus en plus importante surtout dans
les grandes entreprises qui sont disons
qu'ils ont des ressources humaines qui
sont devenus très organisés et il ya eu
beaucoup de progrès dans ce domaine mais
aussi les candidatures spontanées là on
a aussi fait beaucoup de candidatures
spontanées et il ya même quelques
entreprises pour laquelle on n'a fait
que des candidats spontanés
avec comme idée bien sûr que sur le
marché du travail
nous notre situation c'est l'objectif
c'est très important de le dire c'est
pas d'évaluer une politique d'entreprise
cessé de se placer à la place d'un
candidat al embauche demi mais en fait
une recherche d'emploi et on sait il ya
beaucoup il ya une littérature
considérable qui peut le kick il atteste
que en matière de recherche d'emploi il
ya différents canaux il ya différents
outils qui sont utilisés notamment le
bouche à oreille notamment les
candidatures spontanées des prises de
contact de façon assez nature spontanée
mais il n'y a ni phoning aussi alors non
uniquement les correspondances donc
c'est uniquement des courriels qu'on
aura mis uniquement des courriels et
c'est pas simplement donc des candidats
spontanés et des réponses à les offres
c'est aussi des simples demandes
d'information on demande d'information
sur quelles sont les voies et quand pour
déposer ma candidature comment déposer
ma bonne et graphique comme du rapport
une comptabilité une candidature
spontanée ou une réponse à une offre
la discrimination est à peu près la même
on a les mêmes écarts un merci le
souligner et ça c'est un point vraiment
si ces débats où la méthodologie
franchement je trouve que c'est pas ça
le vrai débat on est bien on va dire
terminée parce que c'est un point
intéressant c'est que
les résultats agrégés sur l'ensemble des
entreprises on parle de 40 entreprises
mais en fait on a un pool entreprises
beaucoup plus large que de 103
entreprises mais qu on observe les 40 ou
les 103 les résultats qu'on a au niveau
agrégé sur les pénalités liées à
l'origine les pénalités liées à
l'adresse sont exactement les mêmes
qu'on observe les offres d'emploi d'un
côté ou qu'on observe les candidatures
spontanées l'eau et à l'arrivée les
résultats allaient ce qui valide les
méthodologies cette entreprise est
épinglé air france accor hôtels altran
arkema renault rexel et sautera steria
expliquez nous en quoi ces sept là sont
plus que les autres suspects et de
discrimination alors il faut bien être
précis sur le fait qu'on dit entreprises
épinglées
encore une fois je pense pas qu'on n'est
pas en train d'évaluer des politiques
d'entreprise
on est en train d'évaluer des
comportements de personnes dans
l'entreprise qui parfois oriente de
façon biaisée à tel ou tel candidat a
une préférence pour orienter la lente
reprise aucun talent elle c'est les
interlocuteurs dans 16 entre les
matières de distinction entre notre
boîte en matière de discrimination c'est
toujours des personnes dans les
entreprises
hermann ebongue il vous surprennent ses
résultats oui parce que ces résultats
viennent nous rappeler ici que là
n'était vraiment besoin encore qu'est ce
que vous serez prêt non non mais je lui
dis que oui
au-delà du fait même que ça ne me
surprend pas puisque nous avons fait
réaliser l'étude
il ya deux ans avec
yannick l'horty justement sur le grill
et tu t'appelles l'étude birman qui a
révélé qu'ils n'étaient pas spécifique
sur al embauche mais qui a montré aussi
ses résultats a coopté qu'on les voit
non nous ça ne me surprend pas parce que
c'est mon quotidien
les suisses racisme mais ce que je
voulais disque au delà de hisser le
résultat est d'ailleurs on y reviendra
certainement si le débat sur la
méthodologie en soi n'est pas le
problème parce que et que ce soit par
rapport à des candidatures spontanées à
la réponse aux offres
en tout cas c'est pas les mêmes
pressions pour tout le monde donc il ya
manifestement un problème et donc le
vrai problème qu'aujourd'hui du ce que
cette étude révèle c'est que les gens
doivent au moins prendre conscience et
pas que les entreprises parce que là
pour l'instant opale de l'entreprise
mais je crois que l'état a aussi une
responsabilité dans les solutions qui
doivent être apportées dont les
dernières dans cette étude parce que
c'est l'état qui a commandé mais je
pense que les riches doivent d'abord
venue de l'état c'est nouveau que l'état
fasse du testing avant c'était les
associations il faut aller vers plus de
testing plus de name and shame parce que
là encore c'est nouveau c'est une
promesse d' emmanuel macron pendant la
campagne nommée les couvrir de honte pca
le name and will à dire que cette fois
ci c'est plus seulement du testing et
ont gardé résultats pour soi on publie
on placarde d'une certaine façon vous
êtes favorable à cette méthode là ah oui
oui je suis complètement favorable
d'ailleurs le testing n'a pas pour but
d'épingler telle ou telle entreprise en
tout cas le premier testing qui est
aujourd'hui le premier qui a été qu'il a
été rendue publique n'a pas pour le
objectif d'épingler telle ou telle
entreprise
il a l'objectif de mettre l'accent sur
un sujet qui existe aujourd'hui dans
notre pays
moi je suis député d'une circonscription
où on a un taux de chômage qui explose
mais avec un taux de vacance d'emploi
qui je crois défie tous les renards mage
qui explosent pour les jeunes de moins
de 10 compris pour les français issus de
l'immigration plus grand plus important
que les autres atouts vous regardez la
ville de trappes et celle d'elancourt à
côté effectivement nous avons
quand même des français issus de
l'immigration qui sont assez favoriser
très nombreuses et des favoris il n'y a
pas n'y a pas de statistiques sur les
critères ethniques mais on sait que 80%
de la population à trappes est issu de
l'immigration
donc là très clairement dans toute
vacance qui explose donc sur l'autre
dans les entreprises qui se situe à
trappes et pour autant il n'y a pas de
rencontre entre l'offre et la demande
donc il faut il faut publier il faut
publier maintenant pour revenir sur ce
que met les moyens
ce que les moyens qui sont mis par le
gouvernement il y en a un certain nombre
on a relancé des hangars en france elle
est un peu vidéo va devenir autonome et
c'est effectivement aussi des choses
qu'on est aimé parler des causes
je vous donne avec guy mais d'abord la
réponse des entreprises d'une certaine
façon pas je remercie aussi lortie
d'avoir précisé parce que depuis ce
matin on n'entend absolument tout et
n'importe quoi sur cette étude qui
paraît très intéressante qui révèle un
sujet grave qui était malheureusement
connu et qu'on a beaucoup de mal à
régler
vous avez dit tout à l'heure monsieur
lors quelque chose de très important qui
est de dire on juge pas des politiques
d'entreprise on juge pas des volontés
d'entreprise
on juge des comportements d'individus
monsieur black ops qui a dit tout à
l'heure a donc c'est les terrasses non
c'est pas les drh
c'est bien je n'en reviens vous avez dit
ça mais peu importe ce que le dire par
là c'est à dire créer tenté de le dire
par là c'est que on va parler parce que
c'est un sujet important mais en cela
toute la politique de m une chaîne qui
vient d'être défendue est injustifiée
par votre étude
je voulais pas vous parce qu'on dit si
on évalue des individus alors pourquoi
balancer les noms d'entreprises premier
point deuxième point je sais qu'il y a
plus d'entreprise ya une 30 entreprises
qui n'ont pas été si on croit qu'on a
pas que nos accords je ne suis pas
certain pas vous on n'est pas explosif
avoir une éventuelle non pas par
protection mais parce que je suis pas
sûr que ça va danser grand chose ça vous
iris et moi mais je sais bien
le 5 ici je joue un rôle particulier
donc laissez moi terminer je vous
donnais un contenant le sujet vous
donnez un contre exemple lorsque l'index
égalité homme femme qui est un autre
problème
tout aussi grave et sortir l'égalité
salariale dans la grille salariale il y
avait aussi le fait que les entreprises
devaient le font d'ailleurs publier
leurs taux vous savez plus de 75 75
certaine manière on a pu dire un moment
un autre assez du name and shame celles
qui sont en dessous 75 mais il n'y a pas
eu ce débat
pourquoi n'y a pas eu ce débat pas à
cause du sujet mais parce qu'il n'y a
pas eu de débat sur l'objectivation est
là jauron hommage au gouvernement qui
avait fait un travail d'index qui
permettait justement d'évaluer en
profondeur sur l'année venant avec des
critères totalement objective et reflet
de la réalité pris la discrimination ou
vous ne l'aviez pas jamais jamais alors
on va essayer de comprendre pourquoi il
ya minable et me disent c'est pas du
tout nouveau cette affaire là vous avez
beaucoup travaillé là dessus des films
le plafond de verre le fleuve fondu
aires en 2004 qui était déjà sur les
mêmes questions mais c'était surtout
donc c'est avec ce film que nous avons
pu commencer à travailler avec les
entreprises etc
mais que dit la discrimination en france
il faut dire les mots c'est une
discrimination raciale liés aux préjugés
coloniaux
c'est que ça au jour on a eu l'habitude
on parle encore de français issus de
l'immigration
c'est ce qu'à un moment donné ça sarah
lane enlève issus de l'immigration et
ont dit des français le problème
déjà dans les années 2004
la problématique pour moi c'était de
faire un film sur l'invisible les
discriminations comment vous pouvez
prouver que vous êtes discriminés donc
ça a été tout le travail de mon film
pendant deux ans au delà des testings
c'était d'essayer de comprendre les
jeunes discriminer c'est à dire moi j'ai
pris les bac + 5
donc bac + 5 j'envoie des cv j'en envoie
jusqu'à
ils 200 g 0 entretien 0 donc fait en
ça c'est en 2004 et ils sont vingt cinq
dans l'inconscient collectif
est ce que quelqu'un qui s'appelle
mohamed peut être reçue il habita
attrape les bac + 5
le la république a fait son travail à la
forme et des bacheliers ils ont ils sont
monté rapidement leurs parents était
éboueur était voilà vivait dans tel
quartier
eux ils sont arrivés comme patrick sauf
que sur la ligne de départ on laisse
mohamed là et c'est ça donc si c'est
dramatique dans notre société
d'autant que lorsque jusque là y'a pas
de problème
et à partir de là c'est qu'ils alors je
suis désolé monsieur vous êtes là vous
représentez des drh les drh ont une
responsabilité énorme
en même temps soufflait par leur
direction qu'est ce que ça veut dire ça
veut dire les recruteurs les verra les
prêts dans ses préjugés racisme c'est le
jeune rom jean ses filets la non non il
ne met pas le mot on ne met pas les mots
on est dans on est en train de faire un
acte et c'est l'acte raciste
il est clair et il est sain bah c'est
pas mal mais vous ne pouvez pas jeter
l'opprobre sur la totalité compression
des pages c'est permis
mais noah et sur les la parole pour
juste ma phrase je vous dis que les drh
ont une responsabilité dans leur société
donc ils ont une responsabilité se
disent voilà il s'appelle mohamed certes
il est pas que +5
ça peut aller pour ça mais c'est quand
même un cv entre guillemets exotiques ça
va être compliqué pour le plus tard donc
je ne mets pas tout de suite le doigt
dans l'engrenage
je vais les cartes et pas pour des
raisons racistes c'est pour des raisons
du préjugé que l'on m'a envoyé dans ce
non dit et cette invisibilité
alors ça c'est en 2001 quand ça déjà je
vous assure c'est moi contre vous on
voit la réalité et à partir de là à
partir de la laisser ces jeunes parce
que eux ne demandent pas l'emploi il
ils veulent la compétition moi je suis
pour légiférer
il n'y a pas d'autres moyens c'est pas
possible en 2004 on s'est battu comme
des mets des malades on a deux mois
pendant trois ans je n'ai pas réalisé
pour aller débattre pour expliquer pour
aller dans le partout et on est là
aujourd'hui en train alors on va venir à
la question de savoir s'il faut ou pas
vous répondez et puis on passe aux
solutions géant réaction était due au
fait qu on ne peut pas dire les drh sont
responsables avec une impulsion de leur
direction s'est par exemple parce que si
on sais je sais je sais ce que je vais
dire on va pas on va pas on va pas s'il
vous justement alors y avait plusieurs
choses d'abord je ne crois pas que les
entreprises sont totalement inactive
face à ce sujet ce n'est pas exact pour
preuve
d'abord il ya un certain de choses qui
se sont créés et d'association avec qui
on travaille que vous connaissez tous
qui font un travail formidable
d'ailleurs avec qui on travaille et qui
a une vraie lutte quotidiennement des
intercités et là vous avez raison c'est
qu'en 2004 je ne sais pas
tout le monde connaît saïd hammouche de
mozaïk rh ou monde koné moussa dé
déterminer qui fait un travail
extraordinaire
j'ai présidé quatre ans le troc alors
été rejeté
on a réussi avec des gradins ou faut
faire la même chose
non mais exactement je pense que c'est
important je pense que c'est important
de faire surgir c'est qu'on ne peut pas
je ne crois pas je ne crois pas qu'ils
aient des politiques volontaristes de
discrimination pilotés par des drh dsi
en général ce n'est pas exact un point
qui n'est pas une remise en cause de
méthodologie monsieur attendait dire
bonjour aux associations des amis non je
ne sais pas s'il n'y a pas non ce n'est
pas si jeudi 6 à ce sujet j'ai dit que
des entreprises travaillent et que sa
session déjà depuis déjà longtemps
ensuite j'en ai pour deux minutes
il ya eu des méthodes de recrutement
vous connaissez certainement qu'ils sont
assez anciennes qui sont de plus en plus
utilisées et qui d'ailleurs moi comme
drh peut paraître beaucoup plus
intelligente que le cv qui sont des
méthodes vous savez par aptitudes qui
consiste à prendre des gens pour garder
ce qu'ils savent faire et non pas ce
qu'ils qui ils sont et ça ça sera
intéressant je sais pas si monsieur le
retiennent statistiques là dessus de
voir si à ce moment elle chiffres bouge
je pense que ça serait intéressant de
regarder ce soir croit pas à des
politiques volontaristes
je ne dis pas qu'il n'ya pas de problème
on comprend pas dire à quelqu'un un
moment à aucun moment où dit que oui
peut-être que les rh ont aussi ce
qu'elle a dit une responsabilité des rh
parce que le sujet de recrutement
revient quand même qu'en grande partie
première des choses c'est la rhk et
lorsqu on dans cette étude
à aucun moment la famille j'ai plutôt
l'impression que vous dites que mais les
erreurs n'ont aucune réponse alors dans
une laque à lyon la question ça je n'ai
que d'ailleurs je mette en place des
méthodes déjà rien des méthodes à
l'entreprise mais des plateformes
central qui permet de contrôler ils
seront sans doute pas mais je voulais
vous vous interrogez je voudrais qu'on
parle ans et du cv anonyme est ce qu'il
faut une loi sur le cv anonyme juste
dans un instant mais vous avez dit c'est
à l'état de faire ces testings ce sont
aux pouvoirs publics de faire appliquer
la loi où sont les inspecteurs du
travail dans les entreprises puisque
c'est leur job pour justement obligé à
faire changer les mentalités
allez je vais dire de certains
recruteurs pas forcément tous je veux
dire la mentalité elle doit pas s'opérer
au niveau elle doit pas incomber
uniquement la responsabilité des
inspecteurs du travail
c'est une mentalité qui doit changer à
tous les niveaux et là où je ne vous
rejoint pas monsieur c'est pas question
de il n'est pas question de dire que les
entreprises discrimine volontairement il
est question c'est pas ça le sujet
évidemment que les entreprises ne
discrimine pas volontairement mais
est-ce que la discrimination existe bien
évidemment qu'elles existent avec mon
nom en habitant à trappes je peux te
dire je peux vous dire que j'en ai été
victime
donc il faut pas dire que la
discrimation et discrimination n'existe
pas elle existe deux manières s'envole
n'a pas l'air je viens aux entreprises
parfois même volontairement
là aussi je peux vous dire que je les ai
subi parfois involontairement parce que
il y à ces préjugés dont madame
benguigui a fait référence
il y à ces préjugés qui sont dans les
mentalités ancré dans les mentalités je
vous propose ce que seront pas seuls et
validé c'est vraiment aujourd'hui de
changer
alors de changer de mentalité quand ils
nous prennent conscience que ce sujet
existe mais qu'il n'a plus sa place
faut-il en 2020 en france le cv anonyme
faut-il le rendre obligatoire pourquoi
tant d'atermoiements on en parlait avec
stéphane dans son pays il ya un instant
on voit cela avec hélène bonduelle
assemblée nationale a adopté le projet
de loi relatif à l'égalité des chances
quand nous sommes quelques mois après
les émeutes de 2005 en banlieue
le gouvernement veut lutter contre les
discriminations et présente la loi
égalité des chances à l'assemblée
nationale les députés centristes et
socialistes votent un amendement
instaurant le cv anonyme obligatoire
pour les entreprises de plus de 50
salariés
mais la victoire va être de courte durée
le décret d'application tarde à être
adoptés et finalement peu d'entreprises
le mettre en place
trois ans plus tard la droite relance
l'idée mais sous forme d'expérimentation
le cv anonyme doit être basée sur le
volontariat des entreprises seuls 50
acceptent l'anomalie c'est que nous
avons une loi qui votait depuis 2006 et
que normalement une loi s'applique et
annoncer qu'on va expérimenter une loi
je trouve que ça c'est vraiment dommage
meilleure façon de d'empêcher le cv
anonyme ne fonctionnait ce serait de
rendre obligatoire tout de suite mais
certains que les entreprises trouverai
d'autres moyens en particulier
l'entretien d'embauché pour le contrôle
isc et l'enthousiasmé ne revient pas les
associations montent au créneau
en vain et en 2015 le président hollande
en terre le cv anonyme
nous avons considéré que c'était pas une
bonne idée et que ça se retourne mm
contre ce qui était supposé en être les
bénéficiaires
donc le cv anonyme n'a pas été retenu
samuel thomas fait partie de ceux qui
militent depuis des années pour son
anonymat
c'est une erreur d'avoir enterré le cv
anonyme parce que ça reste la mesure la
plus coercitives qu'on puisse donner à
une entreprise on peut dire à une
entreprise si vous me prouvez que vous
avez un autre processus qui garantit la
non discrimination et que vous mais
apporter la preuve que vous avez mis en
oeuvre des actions significatives emploi
dit ok on n'a pas besoin de vous imposer
2 cv anonyme vous vous avez un vrai
travail qui est mené de vigilance d'auto
testing de contrôle etc
mais celles qui n'ont pas ce vrai
travail
il faut leur imposer ses vannes nîmes
mais pas plus que ses prédécesseurs
emmanuel macron on est convaincus par le
cv anonyme alors voilà une nouvelle
opération de testing pour évaluer les
discriminations à l'embauché dans les
entreprises cette sur les quarante
études j sont épinglés nommé est ce
efficace
le groupe accor qui a été incriminé pour
discrimination il ya 20 ans il était
passé au cv anonyme pour cesser la
discrimination finalement comme il y
avait plus de pression
il a retiré de ces anonymes et il est
reparti dans des vieilles pratiques de
discrimination et donc l'ennemi intime
c'est pas une pression suffisante parce
que c'est un coup et puis tellement les
médias vont l'oublier dans quelques
semaines oublié aussi les formations
anti-discrimination imposées aux
entreprises depuis la loi égalité
citoyenneté de 2017
elles ne sont quasiment jamais appliquée
nadery pourquoi vous ne le faites pas
c'est franchement c'est incompréhensible
alors moi je suis vraiment extrêmement
partagées sur le cv anonyme parce que le
cv anonyme
qu'est-ce qu'il garantit il garantit de
décrocher un entretien d'embauché
il garantit pas l'embauchent est garanti
juste qu'on se retrouve face au but mais
ça donne la chance à wimbledon c'est ça
qui tue mais sur ces deux jeunes veulent
arriver qui n'est même pas convoqué mm à
à la scène
édition jeux qu'ils se à l'entretenir en
eau gire hâte son embauche il va dire
bon c'est pas grave la prochaine fois je
serai même année il va pas se dire j'ai
été discutée en moi je pense que c'est
encore pire parce que et non mais je
pense que c'est encore pire d'avoir
d'avoir d'avoir obtenu ce rendez vous
coiffant je suis retrouvé en face parce
que je vous racontais juste une punaise
ça veut dire que l'on y aurait du
racisme en excuser juste une petite
anecdote n'en a pas moins personnel où
j'ai mis cinq mois avant de trouver un
contrat en alternance quand toutes mes
amies avec un os franco français ont mis
à peine quinze jours j'ai mis cinq mois
en ratant cinq mois d'études et le jour
de mon entretien d'embauché afin d' pour
mon contrat en alternance et j'arrive
devant le recruteur et qui me dit ah
vous êtes blonde et bien là on voit
qu'il ya un vrai sujet il ya un vrai
sujet une fois que vous êtes face aux
recruteurs il n'est pas garanti qui vous
recrutent et la chance qu'on peut lui
donner si le recruteur avait l'intention
de donner la chance et je le donnerai
également sale et délabré avec votre nom
c'était
ok il était beaucoup plus compliqué je
ne décrochait pas du tout deux fait un
dorama herman amical juste vous dire
d'expliquer que peu d'outils bien sûr je
pense que l'erreur
je vous ai conseillé de les partager je
vous ai pas les relances et à certains
bleus pensé que mes cv anonyme va régler
mais le cv anonyme comme je viens de le
souligner ça permet de faire avancer les
choses d'abord dû donner la chance parce
qu'il faut bien comprendre ce qui se
passe c'est qu'il ya des gens qui n'ont
même pas la chance de pouvoir accéder à
un entretien d'embauché
et je vais vous dire de notre expérience
de ce que nous avons fait parce que je
pense que mon coeur restera six mois une
très très longue expérience
c'est nous qui avons mis sur la place
publique et et testing et ça je peux
vous dire licorne travailler ensemble et
ça pue fait avancer les choses et les
résultats c'est qu'il y en a certains
qui par le biais des cv anonymes
ça peut être cassé certains préjugés
parce que je vaux bilé ce terminal et
les préjugés donc vous vous plaidez pour
le cv à jeûner mousse jean la loi gérant
a légiféré non mais non il faut pas non
plus non parce que le problème est
obligatoire même quand il ya un mariage
dans les nous parce que penser que dans
mettons le cv anonyme
ça va ça va tout régler des nations
possible parce que le pur pour terminer
parce que les débats je sais pas si
c'est pas juste la discrimination c'est
une sorte de madeleine des processus
parce que je jécistes est tout à l'heure
sur l'exemplarité de l'état parce que
les discriminations de manière générale
aujourd'hui il ya l'étude qui a été fait
que les entreprises frier apprécié oui
d'accord le centre on l'a dit ont testé
les entreprises d'état je pense que vous
serrez coûter un peu plus supris parce
que vous allez lui non mais alors en
dernier tour de table très rapidement
yamina benguigui vous aurez la parole
est allé moi je voulais juste dire
il s'est passé l'analyse dans d'autres
pays il faut avoir l'humilité de
regarder ce qui s'est passé ailleurs
pour savoir comment ça marche
déjà on ne veut pas se dire les choses
le problème de la discrimination elle et
raciale elle est liée à l'histoire
française elle est liée à l'histoire
coloniale
vous avez souvent votre vernis corps et
une histoire coloniale exactement
certains ont pu régler moi je parle par
exemple des états unis à un moment donné
il ya le problème de de l'égalité des
avec le des noirs et 64 ans et mon
première loi au bout d'un an ils se sont
aperçus que si ils n'accélérait pas les
choses dans si on comptait que sur la
bienveillance des gens a fallu cinq ans
pour changer l'avant et de volontarisme
non non non non non non mais c'est très
grave je vais vous dire juste
actuellement il se passe aussi des
choses très graves parce qu'on vient de
parler on a beaucoup parlé des arabes en
a dit un nom à consonance maghrébine et
sais c'est qu'aujourd'hui au lieu les
choses ont évolué différemment parce que
maintenant on est aussi dans un dans un
contexte international avec le nom qui a
maintenant une consonance musulmane de
maghrébine il est passé maintenant à
musulmane et ça devient eux deux
maintenant encore plus complet encore
plus compliqué on ne vous entend et on
entend par une inquiétude il est urgent
d'agir
mais il est plus urgent vous avez
vraiment même pas 20 secondes chacun les
barrettes sammaritano paquet de temps
d'autant que les demoiselles dans coal
avait un nom mais pas plusieurs reprises
indiqué ce que le gouvernement fait le
gouvernement lance ce testing vraiment
de grande ampleur comme jamais ça n'a
été fait aux propos destinés à lancer
mais le gouvernement voulait faire le
gua mois dans la gym le gouvernement
agit en faveur de ces de c2c de ces
jeunes ou des ses habitants pendant un
quart des ravens a bien évidemment
remettre et nommé il ya un plan qu'a été
lancé le plan d'action pour les
quartiers pour le travail et l'emploi
qui a été lancée où on demande aux
entreprises de signer ce pacte avec le
ministre de la ville et du logement va
c'est pas une légion de contrat c'est
aller au mali
c'est vrai lancé auguin passionnés et au
final la fusée jusqu'à passionnés s'il
vous plaît le cv anonyme ne suffit pas
en lui même évidemment c'est pourquoi il
y assure me anne verger vous qu'ils vont
me tuer non mais c'est pourquoi il ya
des mesures qu'allez vous faire
c'est vraiment le président macron il
peut s'il le veut passer à l'étape
au-dessus c'est pas possible qu'on se
revoie vous serez aux côtés des preuves
dans tout ça c'est que je suis comme
vous d'accord avec vos besoins la presse
les entreprises les drh que vous
représentez évidemment les entreprises
accompagne déjà premier point deuxième
point je trouve toujours dommage que sur
des sujets aussi graves est aussi
important vous avez soutenu
il est impossible d'avoir un débat sont
passés à des accusations d un des sujets
la troisième sera là dedans et troisième
sujet je crois que le cv anonyme je suis
pas totalement convaincu là c'est
vraiment le métier qui vous parle
d'abord parce que ça fait repousser le
problème c'est vrai que ça me permet
d'avoir un entretien vous il faut savoir
le jour du retrait de moins en moins par
cv tout simplement parce que c'est par
linkedin est là linkedin s'est pas
franchement anonyme je vous la suite je
vous l'assuré c'est vrai merci
infiniment est ce que vous savez de quoi
parlent les députés en ce moment toute
la journée ben moi je dis oui c'est la
réforme des retraites et sur lcp et bien
on en parle chaque jour avec elsa monde
à gaven cette réforme et cette course de
lenteur sa montagne d'amendements c'est
son point retraite sont l'accueil tout
[Musique]
bonsoir lda bonsoir l'examen dans la
douleur de cette réforme se poursuit
donc en commission spéciale ici au
palais bourbon on voit ce qu'on en ait
ce soir on en à l'article 9 instaurant
un régime à points c'est à dire que les
députés ont voté l'instauration d'un
régime universel la fin des régimes
spéciaux mais en réalité myriam on en
est un peu nulle part pourquoi et bien
parce que chaque réunion commence comme
ça écoute et nous avons examiné hier 245
amendements il nous reste donc 20 mille
huit cent quatre amendements à examiner
en reste 20099 1393 amendements et il
nous en reste donc 10 7782 voilà il ne
reste plus que dix sept mille
amendements à examiner donc tout le
monde se rend bien compte en fait et
bien que cette commission spéciale elle
ne pourra pas arriver au bout de ses
travaux avant la séance publique
ça donne donc une ambiance assez étrange
pour essayer d'aller un petit peu plus
vite la présidente de la commission à
limiter l'expression pour les
amendements identiques ça donne des
prises de parole à une minute très
rapide
ajoutez à cela le fait que certaines
parties du texte renvoie à la
concertation des partenaires sociaux ou
encore à des ordonnances et bien
l'examen il est laborieux il est pas
très fluide
alors on parle quand même du fond des
débats deux philosophies s'affrontent
pour les insoumis c'est clair votre
majorité
elle veut juste qu'on travaille plus
longtemps écouté ce qu'en dit le député
du nord adrien catena c'est la réponse
du rapporteur nicolas turquois en
réalité le maquereau nice nous fait
regretter et l'honnêteté de la droite
républicaine parce que la bb oui mais je
vais vous le dire vous en faites vous
êtes tout simplement des gens de droite
maquillant progressiste mais il ya une
droite républicaine en face de vous qui
s'assume et qui dit nous nous voulons
une mesure d'âge voilà assumer ce que
vous faites vous ne faites que ça en
quelque sorte vous êtes juste en train
d'essayer de déportés l'âge effectif de
départ jeu proposé à madame la
présidente de que que la majorité puisse
sortir ce qui est tellement eu un coup
de foudre de monsieur cap menaces à
l'égard des républicains donc je je
préfère que nous les laissions partager
ce moment de
de d'allégresse et de voilà ces scellés
miracle de l'amour
la commission elle se poursuit ce
week-end et la semaine prochaine égal
alors il ya un autre rendez vous la
semaine prochaine à l'agenda de la
majorité c'est ce rendez vous que les
députés marcheurs ont avec le président
de la république il faut renouer le lien
abîmé il faut le dire entre la majorité
et le président après certains étaient
très en colère et ils l'ont fait savoir
après le fiasco sur le congé parental
après un décès d'enfants exactement les
députés déjà il aurait bien aimé avoir
une invitation un peu plus directe du
président de la république puisque
certains ont un prix cet événement par
médias alors pour recréer du lien
c'était un petit peu compliqué vous le
savez dans ces cas de crise on parle
d'opération de calinothérapie et bien
une députée me disais moi je n'ai pas
besoin qu emmanuel ma qu'on me fasse de
câlins j'aimerais juste qu'on puisse
échanger c'est ça que beaucoup députés
de votre groupe regrette c'est pas avoir
de temps des changes en petit comité
avec le président de la république
ils l'ont avec le premier ministre
edouard philippe alors c'est sûr mardi
soir les mots ils vont compter
effectivement il ya des mots malheureux
du président de la république qui ont
fait mal à certains députés du groupe la
république en marche quand il a parlé d'
humanité justement dans le cas de ce
couac sur le congé pour les parents
endeuillés
en tout cas emmanuel macron on le sait
dans ces moments il peut être très bon
pour galvaniser un petit peu les troupes
surtout que les municipales c'est dans
quelles que soient ses sur d'éclat de
leur jeu et sait séduire on n'a pas le
temps de pour vous faire rire c'était le
voir absolument giresse de l'intérieur
je tiens à dire qu'en un trade pour une
retraite a perdu me parler à présent un
peu de vous et de vos projets yamina
benguigui je le disais vous partez en
tournée pour l'afrique où votre
documentaire est distribué dans
plusieurs pays ont pour un extrait
d'abord ça s'appelle le dernier poumon
du monde
direction le congrès
le débit du fleuve congo qui classe
comme comme deuxième fleuve du monde qui
mesure 3 million 700 kilomètres carrés
et qui regroupe 10 pays voisins du congo
c'est un massif forestier aussi donc
quand il alors automatiquement et à la
fois au tour donc les arbres qui sont
dans cet espace on pourra que c'est
christ et le cadre donc tout ce qui a
comme pollution en matière dégagement
des émissions des gaz à effet de serre
en europe et etats unis qui viennent
c'est cette forêt qui s'est créé son
carbone pour éviter que le cadre ce
retour dans l'atmosphère et on ne prenne
ce qu'on appelle l'effet de serre
l'afrique avec notre fleuve a été choisi
comme le poumon du monde donc c'est une
fierté pour nous d'avoir le plan parce
que le corps sans loppement les héros et
je salue nos joyeux chroniqueurs alex
taylor bonsoir bertrand dicale qui va
sonner comme chaque vendredi
bonsoir de france info raphaël legendre
de l'opinion pour tout comprendre de
l'actualité économique et des chouchous
à camille saféris vous allez voir ils
arrivent à faire sortir de même quelques
députés mais un mot d'abord de votre
votre documentaire le bassin du congo 3
milliards de tonnes de carbone
on parle jamais 30 30 milliards il vient
ça a été je j'ai fait ce film
à un moment donné il ya deux ans on a
découvert la plus grande tourbière du
monde une tourbière c'est une forêt
primaire avec un sol marécageux qui
séquestrent 30 milliards de tonnes de
co2 c'est en plein en plein coeur du
bassin du congo qui est le deuxième
poumon du monde par code l'amazone et 6
à le chasser les de cette forêt là et du
coup c'est suite un peu au débat que
nous avions
j'ai voulu aller prendre la parole
des scientifiques africains et des
africains donc c'est un film sur
l'écologie ou d'être lé cinéaste en
obligations par les décombres absolument
on ne peut pas aujourd'hui se dire bon
ben voilà on entend parler de l'écologie
et tout mais nous devons faire
nous cinéastes aussi ce travail et ce
travail je l' ai commencé en afrique et
vous allez repartir en afrique pour
terminer avant de entendre tous nos
chroniqueurs vous êtes un petit mode du
film avec isabelle adjani raschke jaouen
le besco maïwenn rachida brakni et
tourné à ercis et tournée s'est terminée
et je suis en train de terminer le
montage et j'ai commencé à tourner la
confection en algérie absolument c'est
une c'est l'histoire de deux de trois
soeurs algérienne née en france
voilà qui au départ des comics non il
faut vraiment fallait donc je salue au
passage au bloc notes vous avez que des
bo gars seront petit 2020
ils vont parler pour vous le bloc-notes
petit et on commence avec l'économie
raphaël alors aujourd'hui vous avez
décidé de nous parler d'une vieille
passion français oui même de 2 myriam
une vieille passion des français pour
râler vous savez autour du déjeuner le
dimanche midi on aime bien débattre et
se chamailler et alors si en plus on
parle des impôts alors là c'est un
festival
alors que les français râlent quand les
impôts augmentent bas on peut le
comprendre les regarde et je vous ai
trouvé un petit graphique cette semaine
qui vous montre l'évolution la pression
fiscale sur les ménages
ces dernières années de 2010 à 2018
on voit que les impôts sur les ménages
ou augmenter de soi sans ces
impressionnants milliards d'euros on
peut comprendre la grogne populaire
bon ce qui est plus étonnant c'est
qu'elle inverse regardez bien tout lien
pour vous oui ça descend ça descend lac
labelle et bien malgré le fait que sa
baisse et vers les gens râlent quand
même c'était cette céréale
vous parlez d'une étude qui a été
publiée par le fc le fc eux c'est un
centre de recherches économiques plutôt
classé à gauche qui est relié à sciences
po c'est très sérieux et le fc de chaque
année et étudie l'impact des mesures
budgétaires sur les ménages
et que nous dit le fc cette année est
bien que sur les 17 milliards d'euros de
gains de pouvoir d'achat rhin pour elles
sont félicités depuis 2018 et bien
environ un quart sont allés aux 5% les
plus riches alors que selon leurs
calculs les 10 % des français les plus
modestes auraient perdu en pouvoir
d'achat à cause de la hausse du tabac de
la réforme des apl et de la réforme de
l'assurance chômage ça nous rappelle où
c'est le retour du président des riches
petite musique qu'on entend depuis deux
ans effectivement sur le président des
riches
et alors ça ça beaucoup mais alors
beaucoup énervé le gouvernement cette
semaine
tant et si bien que bruno le maire est
sorti pas plus tard qu'hier on écoute
faire un rapport sur la question de la
justice la politique du gouvernement
n'oubliant d'intégrer un milliard
d'euros de primes d'activités qui vont
précisément en revenus les plus faibles
c'est pas honnête c'est pas sérieux
donc je conteste la méthode oublié
d'intégrer dans ses calculs
par exemple je pourrais citer d'autres
exemples le fait qu'il ya désormais rsa
charge 0 pour les frais dentaires pour
les frais optiques 1 c'est pas honnête
mais c'est pas sérieux
voilà bon voir un ministre qui râlent
lui aussi multirôles sur la méthode
alors bon mettons de côté les arguties
méthodologique
moi je voudrais dire deux choses sur
l'étude de l'ouest la première c'est que
ft fait fausse route en regardant
uniquement la répartition des baisses
d'impôts depuis deux ans parce qu'ils
oublient que depuis dix ans ce sont
aussi les classes moyennes et moyennes
supérieures qui ont payé le gros de la
facture de ces 66 milliards d'euros et
donc il n'est pas totalement anormal que
ce soit aussi peu sûre bénéficie du
reflux la deuxième chose dont nous parle
le fc eux c'est d'expliquer que ce sont
les travailleurs qui ont le plus
bénéficié de ces gains de pouvoir
d'achat depuis deux ans à défaut si je
puis dire des chômeurs et des retraités
alors le problème c'est qu'il ne voit
l'amélioration leur sort que par la
redistribution
or les chômeurs vous avez quand même
quatre chômeurs sur dix sur dix wii qui
est qui vit sous le seuil de pauvreté
c'est bien avec le travail qu'on
réussira à leurs augmenter leur pouvoir
d'achat pas avec les aides sociales qui
permettent uniquement de survivre or le
travail est bien il reprend les
créations d'emplois sont là un million
d'emplois créés depuis cinq ans et ça
c'est grâce à quoi c'est grâce aux
baisses d'impôts aussi qui ont été
décidées lors du quinquennat précédent
40 milliards de baisses d'impôts donc le
message global c'est continuant sa
baisse un peu mais on peut encore y
aller beaucoup plus franchement je
rappelle que la france reste en dépit de
ce rush frileux payante les accès du
monde donc continuer dans cette voie il
ya encore de la marge
vive les baisses d'impôts et l'est de la
france va très bien on part en irlande
vive d'irlande alex les élections
irlandaises c'est demain expliquez-nous
d'abord peut-être vous sélective alors
en passant seulement je fold d'abord
s'il veut dire salut en gaélique
en bouche un coin alors ce sont les
élections les plus excitantes depuis
longtemps car depuis un siècle en fait
ne sais pas si vous avez lu alice de
l'autre côté du miroir il ya deux
journaux qui s'appelle en comble et will
oldham 28-10 joie si dupont avec un thé
dupont avec un dea dans la version
française est en fait fine et folle et
finike c'est exactement la même chose on
coalition depuis un siècle on groupe fim
faisait un peu plus entre gauche et fine
est gay c'est un peu plus entre droite
donc voilà mais là c'est moins sûr
qu'ils continuent cette coalition
oui alors qui va l'emporter du coup
alors on pensait que c'était les idéaux
varadkar qui est le premier ministre tu
es très télégénique surtout à preixan
lorsqu'on voyait pas trop le découvre un
personnellement on va te n'est pas
d'accord et les britanniques le
connaissent très bien parce qu'il passe
pour un peu prendre sur ce que après sa
rencontre avec boris johnson il avait
parlé du royaume uni comme étant un
petit pays
désormais après le bac c'est ce qui ce
qui n'est pas tombée dans l'oreille de
sourds ni à londres ils sont curieux né
à dublin où les gens étaient un peu plus
content donc ils pensaient que c'était
le moment de déclencher des élections
en plus il est illogique il représente
vraiment ce pays qui a changé plus que
tout autre pays dans l'union européenne
il est gay ouvert du monde gay en plus
il est fils d'un médecin indien et d'une
infirmière irlandaise donc c'est
vraiment quelqu'un qui incarne la
nouvelle irlande
mais en fait ce qui avait pas vu c'est
que depuis l'élection de boris johnson
le bail si ça fait un peu pschitt plus
personne ne parle de ça dans la campagne
en fait on revient sur les vieux thann
qui adresse le monde
le logement et la santé bon alors on va
voir ce que vous apportez demandé alors
il y a en fait le grand choc
c'est depuis quelques semaines setchine
fine qui le lennar et l'éthique de ce
qui fut dit rafale à l'armée qui a
milité pour le pour bouter des
britanniques en dehors de l'europe du
nord
le dernier sondage c'est vraiment 121
pour le parti de leon 24 centre droit 23
pour centre gauche mais 25 ans les
rapports pour politique en plus
ils ont un leader enfin une hideuse si
on peut dire très télégénique marie lou
mcdonald qui a étudié les poètes
métaphysique du blanc oui absolument
ancienne députée européenne qui n'a rien
à voir qui c'est de complètement cassé
le lien avec lire alors citerai par
exemple pour moi c'est très bizarre que
je vienne ici en disant que chez une
famille pour moi je dans les années 70
chaque fois qu'on ouvrait la télévision
en grande-bretagne lira les attentats et
chine fine c'était on ne pouvait même
pas entendre leur voix à la télévision
britannique
et là tout d'un coup mais ils vont pas
gagner parce qu'il prévoyait pas d'être
si haut dans les sondages dont ils ont
posé que une quarantaine de députés deux
candidats sur 160 sièges
mais ce qu'ils peuvent faire c'est
qu'ils peuvent casser complètement ces
coalitions éternel entre fini fort effet
michael et s'imposait parce que des deux
parties ont des jambes et on va faire
coalition avec les politiques de ce qui
fut les terroristes même en double ça
choque mais est ce qu'ils pourront
rester comme ça avec 25 points son plus
haut dans les sondages
on le saura demain soir un regard à 3
heures heure française et on a et on
aura tous les moyens de comprendre un
peu mieux les résultats grâce à vous
c'est incroyable quand même le signe
fame 6 oh ça nous ramène quand même
d'une voile à l époque qu'on croyait
révolue on va chanter avec vous les ou
chartres en vous allez nous parler du
baccalauréat c'est ça ça serait
difficile de faire autrement parce que
les premières épreuves du nouveau
baccalauréat les fameuses trois c'est
que passe en ce moment les classes deux
premiers enfin que passer jusqu'à
aujourd'hui beaucoup de classe de
première
beaucoup d'élèves de première se passe
très très mal
la contestation des lycéens fait
qu'elles ont été annulés dans beaucoup
de lycées il ya eu des policiers
intervenant dans des lycées des lycées
en garde à vue à tel point d'ailleurs
que les certitudes du ministre de
l'éducation nationale jean michel
blanquer semble un petit peu vacillé ces
derniers jours y dit qu'ils pourraient
réaménagé certaines modalités de son
ambitieuse réforme du bac et ça nous
rappelle que le bac c'est sacré que
chaque fois qu'on y touche il se passe
quelque chose c'est un scandale
alors je vais vous rappeler un scandale
précédent c'était pas du un mini cd du
un chanteur c'était en 1992 et vous
passiez un belge et un bac à bon marché
et dans un lycée poubelles l'ouverture
habituelle
des horizons le bac g richelle tarder
et quelle magnifique polémique et en
plus c'est une polémique assez paradoxal
parce que la chanson ne parle pas du
tout du bac g elle parle pas du tout des
études elle parle de michel sardou h
dites moi j'ai elle parle de michel
c'est à dire que michel sardou
uniquement michel sardou qui parle de
lui même
mais il y avait ces douze secondes et
ses douze secondes qu'on fait un
scandale magnifique
le ministre de l'éducation nationale de
l'époque lionel jospin était monté au
créneau et c'est parce que c'était quand
même les nullards à l'époque le badge et
c'était les fameux bacs techno qui ont
été amplement réformé depuis et le bac
le bac en france est horriblement
sérieux et notre culture populaire est
pleine des rappels de ce sérieux là il
faut être indispensablement sérieux
devant le bac et ils font entendre alors
cessé un document d'il ya 56 ans est en
1964 il faut entendre le désarroi danny
philip est là elle a 18 ans à l'époque
elle viendra t son bac elle doit
annoncer à son père son échec
écoutez
[Musique]
mon bac je l'aurais parié
s
j'ai toujours
chez moi
c'est nickel
coquine cette chanson alors comment elle
a raté son bac l et philippe mais parce
qu'elle était amoureuse amoureuse d'un
garçon et c'est pour ça qu'elle a raté
son bac mais dans ses bras je suis reçue
je prends ta peau - caniveau moins bien
gagner philippe mais bon c'est pas une
critique du bac en tant que tel alors
dans la chanson gauchistes il y a eu
dans les années soixante dix on s'est
moqué un peu des bons élèves on s'est
moqué des bêtes à concours
mais il n'y a pas vraiment beaucoup de
chansons qui s'entraîne au baccalauréat
de l'autre côté de l'échiquier politique
mais j'en ai quand même trouvé une et
écoutez bien c'est assez étonnant mais
l'ip l'omc sous le bras que je pourrais
faire sciences po ou l'ena qu'entre
centrale hec moi j'aurai le choix
m
debacq
[Musique]
moi qu'est-ce que je devienne dans tout
ça
bien faire de moi à 5 millions de
bacalan
les cookies
c'est une chanson de 1979 c'est la face
à du premier 45 tours de philippe 6 me
alors les érudits de la chanson des
années 80 savent que philippe 6 me c'est
aussi appelé loue des esprits pour
quelques tout petits tubes depuis il est
devenu artiste peintre à mieux mais dans
cette chanson gay plutôt astucieuse il
appelle de ses voeux une réforme du bac
mais au contraire de tous les ministres
successifs qu'ont voulu réformer le bac
lui il veut pas plus de bacheliers mais
plutôt moins de bye bye bye plus vous
allez me dire c'est réac
c'est un soutien à la sélection c'est de
droite ça dit le contraire de tout ce
qu'on dit tous les ministres depuis
l'époque mais bon en même temps depuis
la sortie de cette chanson il ya 40 ans
c'est quand même la première fois que
vous l'entendez il a légèrement
disparaît des radars c'est donc un signe
merci merci beaucoup bertrand on termine
avec vous camille ça vous intéressé
parce que peut-être que vous la
connaissez la députée on va nous parler
khamis oui oui parce qu elle est
productrice enfin elle est ex
productrice de cinéma elle s'appelle
frédéric dumas
voilà donc vous la connaissez je connais
très bien je me suis dit que c'était
l'occasion ou jamais de vous parler
d'elle alors j'ai bu un verre avec elle
elle est députée ex en marche
ex udi aujourd'hui liberté et
territoires et alors elle a produit pas
mal le film a produit timbuktu doberman
des beaux gosses réaliste magnifique
no-man's-land film sur l'assaut sont
grands et puis donc finalement elle a
remplacé le trac de la sortie du
mercredi à 14h par des par des séismes
en blé alors c'est une angoisse
différentes mais enfin c'est aussi un
peu avec des orateurs et il ya des liens
entre le cinéma et l'assemblée
d'ailleurs pour anticiper l'évolution de
la société elle a une suggestion
elle voudrait rendre les parlementaires
plus cinéphiles c'est bien le cinéma
c'est un moyen de montrer la réalité
on l'a vu avec les misérables si j'avais
un corps norme est ce que j'ai dis
souvent aux hommes et aux femmes
politiques
jordi vous devriez les plus souvent
cinéma et vous devriez peut-être l'irbm
des scénarios parce que les scénarios
c'est obligatoirement quelque chose qui
va atterrir un an ou deux ans après
quand le président va voir les
misérables
ce que je crois tout petit peu dommage
c'est qu'il a mis un peu de temps pour y
aller et qui dit je comprends des choses
oui à travers le cinéma on peut
comprendre des choses
donc ça pour moi c'est une manière aussi
de faire la politique c'est pas faux et
voyez donc il ya pas mal de député aussi
on peut se le dire qu'ils auraient pu
être acteur et donc ils sont parfois
faits donc j'ai voulu savoir si frédéric
humain avait parfois des idées de
casting en voyant ses collègues
en fait moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est pas
d'aller choisir des politiques qui
savent jouer qu'ils feraient des
bourreaux acteurs ou des bons comédiens
c'est vrai qu'on a parce qu'il y en a
qui quelque part on ce recul on voit que
j'allais dire une forme de manque de
sincérité et qui joue un jeu et que
quelque part pour tout ça n'est pas très
grave et tout ça est un théâtre
et effectivement ils prennent pas les
choses à coeur en revanche je pense que
quand on mène une action
effectivement et des choses à faire qui
ressemble à du casting
et puis un réalisateur et un producteur
quand on se met d'accord sur un casting
on se met d'accord sur sur une couleur
donnée à côté artistique à l'action
politique mais je trouve ça intéressant
ça serait bien ça fait ressortir les
artistes qui sommeille en aux députés
c'est pas loin je sais pas si ça vous
dois vous parler forcément pas que oui
nos battre averti non mais moi surtout à
sa première intervention
c'est vrai que beaucoup de cinéastes
enfin va on est on est on est beaucoup à
voir travailler sur des sujets qui
arrivait dans celle épaules démaquillant
le débat public quatre cinq ans après et
canto quant aux acteurs politiques y
sont ils sont très mauvais termes
pour terminer pour je vais parler de son
dada parce que tous les to les débuts t
on d'un dada donc pour lâcher prise
et bien phu et frédéric bibal justement
elle fait du cheval et notamment du saut
d'obstacles alors est ce que finalement
ça serait peut-être une leçon pour la
politique
en fait on voit pas regarder l'obstacle
au cheval si on veut sauter correctement
on doit regarder plus loin je pense
souvent
surtout quand le fallait faire refus ou
quand on a un problème à l'autre ça que
je me dis bon quand ça passe ça passe et
puis parce qu'en plus c'est vrai vous
avez raison c'est une leçon de vie le
cheval parce qu ils vous obligent à
faire le contraire de ce que vous auriez
tendance à faire c'est pour ça qu'il ya
des coups de cravache en fait le coup de
cravache
il doit être donné peut-être en tout cas
cheval de manière suffit pas au bon
moment donc souvent politiques ont deux
voilà on a on entend des choses
tellement contradictoires on donne des
ordres contradictoires et pareil que
pour un chat il comprend rien donc il
s'énerve et hop
s'ils donnent un coup de cul commande
ici et là vous éjecter des coups de
cravache vous avez reçus ou pas yamina
benguigui en politique
non non les coups de cravache non mais
ici à l'assemblée nationale c'est quand
même ce qu'on entend dans ça vous manque
cette vie politique ou pas du tout non
c'est pas une vie politique moi j'ai
l'impression que d'aller le délai il
craint que j'avais été élue à paris mais
je ne fais que des films politiques tous
mes films que ce soit mémoires
d'immigrés et cetera le jardin le
plafond de verre c'est où nous sommes de
plain pied dans le politique
donc la politique en soi être là tout ça
c'est non ça nous manque tant merci
d'être venu sur le plateau de lcp merci
les amis c'est le week end profitez bien
à vendredi prochain c'est la fin de
cette émission
merci à vous de l'avoir suivi vous
pouvez retrouvez d'ailleurs cette
émission sur la toute nouvelle chaîne
youtube lcp très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]